[Music]
you did a lot of stuff for this book and
research this book you went to the army
you went to boot camp
yeah I did three days of boot camp in
Fort Knox and they let me fire a tank
which they've never let a civilian do
for good reason
right they let you get into a tank and
fire the gun that's mounted on the tank
you know a lot about endings I never
heard someone say fire a tank that's
just but that's me shoot a tank I still
not sure you get in a tank and you fire
the artillery clearly I put on too much
cream this morning
here's some of the stuff she did you got
in the ring with a UFC fighter to her
Randy Couture I mean that's that takes
some holiday yeah yeah I got some
training from Dana White and he had a
jujitsu expert chock me out which I
don't know how this was helping me fight
they wanted me to know what it felt like
to get choked out right so this guy put
me in a rear naked chokehold and and did
you pass out well they'd never actually
choked out a total [ __ ] before so what
happens is I wanted to help so I started
to try and fall asleep and apparently I
convinced them a little early and then
Dana White looked at me as like did you
dream and I said no he's like you dream
you faked it we're doing it again so
they choked me out twice wait a minute
they're choking you out and you're
trying to go to sleep sure what do you
like reading you know check off or
something and what do you do you I don't
understand what you're doing you know
I'm thinking of a sleepy thing today
all right you you hunted turkeys turkeys
are horrible people I thought I was
gonna feel bad about shooting a turkey
no they out there all they do is they
wake up early in the morning and the
male turkey beats up the the less male
turkey and that makes him watch him have
sex with other female turkeys all that
yeah they're horrible
so turkeys are dicks they have it coming
Jax you should feel much better about
eating turkey you learn how to change a
tire yeah my dad taught me when I was it
you just call triple-a now like it last
time I got a flat I pulled over I was on
Sunset I pulled over and I changed the
tire and I felt really good about it
it's not that hard your voice went up 18
octaves
why would you do that you have a car
which has like some kind of button that
someone comes and does that for you no I
do not so you're driving like a 1973
Plymouth Valiant yeah why who are you
trying to impress in the car with you
know it takes a second to change it
Nandu you've changed a tire it's not
that big a deal
why he's keeping me on this question
good point
cuz Mila when was the last time you
change the tire I never tastes been a
few years ya know I'm within the triple
A's loving the car you were trying to
impress no it was not trying to impress
anybody pop right near the Playboy
Mansion
and I was not try and I said I got to do
this I'm gonna do it what's the big deal
oh my if I were you able to call the
paparazzi immediately I wasn't was I
hoping that drive by yes but they never
do any skills that you learned I
understand that you learned one skill
that you want to share with us there's a
lot of skills but I brought a
switchblade which every man should carry
at all times you never know what you'll
have to do it's very it's challenging to
do this without singing when you're a
jet for trying really hard not to do
right now yeah please dog that but you
just flick it forward and were you scare
you all right
not really I have to say no because you
didn't brandish it the way they do in
movies when they're trying to you didn't
really brandish me oh yes I was turned
on I brand this day I've been picking up
on that cue all right so so you just
flick it yeah all right don't hurt me so
you just flick it like that but what I'm
used to is this kind of
[Applause]
kind of thing
[Applause]
Wow
[Applause]
you